sharks are big fast
Fierce predators
but in their first year of life
they are surprisingly vulnerable
to stay alive they can walk out of water
live in rivers and even eat their
siblings
all in the fight to make it as a baby
shark
sharks are formidable Hunters that have
evolved over 450 million years
they are the most feared creatures in
our seas
great whites with the power to LEAP 10
feet into the air
Mako with speeds of over 45 miles per
hour
but baby sharks don't start out this way
in fact they're a target for Predators
including other sharks
around 80 percent of some shark species
won't make it to adulthood
adult sharks don't spend any time caring
for their newborns
a baby shark is just another item on
their menu
which is why some pregnant sharks like
this one travel to shallow water to give
birth where big predators just can't go
exactly where sharks are born is largely
still a mystery so this footage of a
shark berth is extremely rare
once born many sharks remain in the
safety of the shallows in areas known as
nurseries
like this one
near tropical Orpheus Island on the
Great Barrier Reef
the reef is home to more than 1600
species of fish 82 of them sharks
this black tip reef shark was born just
a few days ago near the mangroves lining
the shore
the above ground root system offers
protection to baby black tips
and many other small animals as well
at around 20 inches in length this young
black tip is a quarter of the size of an
adult
black tips are able to swim from the
moment they're born
they Dart among the Tangled roots in
Nature's playground
but there is no time to play when you're
a hungry baby shark
luckily his mother left him a part in
gift
black tips like many shark pups are born
with extra fats stored in their liver
giving them enough energy to explore
their environment
as they learn to hunt for food
[Music]
venturing into the shallow bay presents
opportunities for a larger meal
[Music]
at three months old he's still quite
small
but within a year he'll double in length
four times the growth rate of a human
baby
what he lacks in size he makes up for in
speed
[Music]
black tips hunt with bursts of over 20
feet per second
he will spend his first 15 months
hunting small fish crabs and octopus
big enough to travel out to the reef
with the adults
[Music]
further south in cooler Waters a bigger
shark with a bad reputation gives birth
on our doorstep
[Music]
in estuaries and rivers where fresh
water meets the sea you'll find bull
sharks
bull sharks are deadly and the most
versatile of all sharks
they are the only shark species that can
move between salt water and fresh water
with special glands near their tail they
are able to regulate salt levels in
their massive bodies
that means they can swim a little too
close to home along beaches and rivers
making human encounters more frequent
than with any other shark
but why swim in fresh water with a vast
ocean to exploit
one reason is to give their babies the
best chance of survival
bull sharks choose shallow water
estuaries to give birth to their young
far from where any other shark species
can go
a newborn bull shark is about as long as
a human arm less than three feet
from birth they have the ability to live
in fresh or salt water
but a receding tide can leave a baby
shark trapped and in grave Danger
despite the safety of river systems
Predators lurk
and baby bull sharks
have few defenses
[Music]
here on Australia's Central East Coast
crocodiles are not a threat
young bull sharks face other pressures
like pollution and habitat loss
which is why Dr Amy smoothie is here to
help track their movements
so these sharks are vulnerable at these
early life stages if really important to
understand their movements and behaviors
so that we can learn about what type of
habitats they're utilizing so that we
ultimately can understand where they're
going when and protect the Sharks and
their habitats that they're using
to catch and tag baby bull sharks Amy
and fisherman Troy billin have been out
setting lines early in the morning when
the sharks are most active pregnant
females come into the Estuary to give
birth late spring early summer we're not
sure exactly how many sharks are in the
Estuary but what we do know is that the
Clarence river is a pupping area and
it's a nursery for bull sharks
foreign
as the sun rises Troy and Amy begin to
check the lines
oh yes we
yes we
oh hello
there's a little male bull shark
and you can see that it's
umbilical scar that was present is still
open
it's just starting to close over so it's
likely that this shark has been born
a few weeks ago
what a beautiful looking fish
male bull shark
wonderful
many people think of bull sharks as big
man-eating Predators however they're not
that they're an apex predator that's
incredibly important to keep a balanced
Marine ecosystem
he is
81 centimeters long or two foot eight
turning the young shark on his back puts
him into a state of tonic immobility
making it easier for a doctor's smoothie
to perform minor surgery so right now
I'm just going to make a small surgical
incision in the abdomen
I'm inserting the acoustic tag
unlike a satellite fin tag this small
device is inserted internally
and we are able to identify the shark
when it comes within 500 meters of a
listening station
satellite tags only receive data when a
shark surfaces but the acoustic tag lets
Amy track the shark's movements with an
underwater receiver and it will work for
up to 10 years
previous tracking has shown baby bull
sharks are incredibly active in
estuaries
traveling more than 60 miles upriver
you are an important apex predator and I
hope I get to see you one day in Sydney
Harbor
by following baby bull sharks as they
grow we can hope to understand how they
use their environment and how bull
sharks and humans can better coexist
by about five years old this shark could
pose a threat to smaller baby sharks
[Music]
foreign
luckily he'll be big enough to expand
his hunting ground out to sea
further north on Australia's East Coast
the babies of another shark
face cannibalism in the womb
the sand tiger shark is one of the most
ferocious looking sharks up to 10 feet
long and over 300 pounds these adults
are big
and intimidating
thankfully sand tigers are extremely
docile toward humans often referred to
as the Labradors of the sea
sand tigers give birth only once every
two years and they never birth more than
two Pops at a time they have the lowest
reproductive rate of any shark
this makes them particularly vulnerable
and their babies especially precious
one of the most important breeding
grounds on the planet for the sand tiger
shark is here just off Rainbow Beach in
Queensland Australia
a place called wolf Rock
volcanic Pinnacles jut up from the Sandy
Bottom
creating a sheltered Oasis in a blue
desert
it's a biodiversity hot spot for fish
race
and turtles
with such a concentration of shark food
it's a perfect place for sand tigers
after mating they gather here in the
hundreds
the females will stay here for several
months as their babies develop
sand tiger sharks have two wombs and
over a 12-month gestation period produce
hundreds of eggs
up to six embryos will start to grow in
each uterus
where life's already a battle
[Music]
there are multiple hungry sharks in each
womb
their only food
eggs
and their siblings
older babies have an advantage
their larger size helps them to
overpower smaller siblings
only one shark in each womb Will Survive
it's a shark eat shark world
even before birth
females keep producing eggs to feed the
largest embryo left in each womb
but it's not just the embryo's size that
gives it an advantage
it's the most aggressive baby sand
tigers that are more likely to be born
that trait is passed down from the males
who initiate mating by biting the female
to hold her
it's a violent affair
[Music]
and the females bear the scars
the most aggressive males mate with the
most females
giving their offspring a genetic
Advantage for success
after a few months only one dominant
baby shark remains in each womb
like this one
similar to human pregnancies you can see
the baby shark moving inside mom's belly
[Music]
after 12 months she'll be born ready to
expand her menu Beyond her siblings
on the other side of the world it's
November off the coast of Cape Cod
at this time of year the Northwest
Atlantic seems an unlikely Sanctuary for
one little-known predator
the poor beagle shark
despite their impressive strength and
speed poor beagles get much less
attention than their cousins
the great white
and the Mako
though pregnant poor beagles are here
they're rarely seen
and scientists are still unraveling
their many Mysteries
we're out here trying to catch the poor
beagle shark which we also like to call
the Phantom shark this is because not a
lot of people have heard of or seen the
poor beagle
pretty difficult to catch and it's
usually found in colder Waters
PhD student
here to study the movements of feel poor
beagles as part of the research
conducted by Dr James sulikowski
they believe that the females stay in
these cold Waters to give birth
the question is why when other sharks
migrate south by winter
Wendy it's cold it's rough out right and
this shark is living here in these
Waters it's the only shark that stays
here year round
one of the unique things about the poor
beagle shark is that it's endothermic
and this means that it can actually keep
its body temperature warmer than the
water temperatures
so we think that they might be using
this spot while they're pregnant to
reduce their competition and have these
unique habitats that they can use that a
lot of other species just they just
can't handle
basically then that chart's coming in
we're going over it let it swim through
it clip it up on the tail yeah yeah we
can leader it
so we need a poor beagle and when we get
one we're going to satellite tag her and
we're also going to see if she's
pregnant that's one of the most
important life history stages you have
to study I mean they're the mobs they're
the ones out there swimming with the
Next Generation so where they go are
areas that we need to know so we can
protect them
because they can thermoregulate poor
beagles are able to use the entire water
column in their search for prey from
warmer water near the surface to much
colder water at depths of over a four
thousand feet
large eyes help them to hunt in deeper
darker water
but this shark has caught the scent of
the bait near the surface
before we go we can see it right there
in the water
the thing just called the circle see it
circling we can see the shark right here
can the scientists catch this massive
shark and bring it on board
that's a nice poor beagle right there
look at that every hook all right this
is the key moment right now we got to
get the shark to the boat
poor beagles are big they're powerful
sharks it's going to take everyone on
board to land the shark safely
all right do I be on this one here we go
all right shark's coming on two tail
ropes
it's a big shark
bringing 400 pounds of pure muscle on
board isn't easy and the crew need to
find Innovative and safe ways of holding
on to it you ready all right here we go
the most important things is to get
water in the shark's mouth which we have
which is great
the scientists must work quickly to keep
the shark healthy so what we're doing
now is going to get some measurements
shark is right now it's a mature animal
this one's a mature male this is a first
James and his team have never caught a
male poor beagle in these Waters at this
time of year
they believed that males migrated
elsewhere after the breeding season yeah
I got the clipboard why is this shark
here now so we're getting a blood sample
so we'll measure this for Reproductive
hormones testosterone for this species
for this male to see what this levels
are and if it's high we know that it's
just made it you've got
females in this area that are pregnant
so it's an incredible area for this
species it's what they need to survive
the best way to study these elusive
sharks is to track them with a satellite
tag attached to their dorsal fin
so the tags that we're using transmit a
location every time this shark comes out
of the water you get a signal of where
that shark is in real time
so what's interesting is that the past
data that we have for females suggests
they use this place year round so it's
really interesting now to catch a mail
to see what they're going to do do they
leave do they stay with the females all
really important when you talk about
conservation and management and how
these animals are using this area
before they return the shark to the
water they have one more measurement to
take
sorry
anal temperature probe this is a
homeothermic shark right so it maintains
its body temperature warmer than the
environment that's why it can live here
while blue sharks and other species that
aren't as good at it leave
all right
you can see that actually the
temperature is going up right right now
74.5 degrees inside this shark and what
we'll do is we'll compare that to what
the water temperature is right now I can
tell you it's about 20 degrees warmer
inside the shark than it is outside
that's absolutely incredible all right
with measurements complete and the new
satellite tag attached it's time to
release this eight foot long male back
into the sea
one two three push
here we go
watch the tail here it goes
wow do you see that swim away that was
amazing that's incredible
marine biologist
real exciting landed a large porbeagle
male which is incredible the shark was
250 centimeters long it's one of the
biggest I've ever seen probably three
four hundred pounds I mean it was a
beast most of our work has focused on
females right it's a really important
sex they're the moms you know where do
they go to give birth but when you catch
a male male's a part of that equation
you know where are they mating you know
is it here and if so when so that's a
really important part of our research
and this is the first male we've ever
Tagged so that Phantom so shark we
finally got the mail so all the pieces
are starting to come together but we
still have such a long way to go
is a rare opportunity to add to the data
on this mysterious species
but there is still a major piece missing
to the Phantom shark puzzle
this ultrasound reveals baby poor beagle
sharks in utero for the very first time
and only eight inches long
where are they born
to answer that the scientists will
return next year
the coast of Southeastern Australia is
home to dozens of shark species
but not all sharks are Mega predators
in the nutrient-rich protected Waters of
Jarvis Bay
many smaller sharks and other creatures
thrive
like the Port Jackson shark
it's also a nursery ground for a baby
Port Jackson's
poor Jackson sharks are found only in
the southern half of Australia
the adults migrate once a year from
deeper colder water offshore to this
secluded Bay to find a mate
it's a Congregation of hundreds maybe
thousands
and recent studies reveal something
extraordinary
returning sharks seek out the same
individuals year after year
males in one group females in another
establishing long-term relationships not
documented in any other shark
multiple males Vie for the attention of
every female
competition is fierce
poor Jackson mating appears to be a
rough affair
most have developed thicker skin than
males to withstand their sharp teeth
males bite the female's fin holding her
in place while he inserts one of his two
claspers
after mating they go their separate ways
[Music]
While most sharks give birth to live
young poor Jacksons lay eggs
to give unborn pups the best chance of
survival this mother wriggles the egg
free into a deep Rocky crevice where
it's protected from predators
her eggs are a unique cone-shaped spiral
nearly five inches in length
over the next few weeks she'll lay up to
16 eggs from multiple partners
the corkscrew-like X will work their way
deeper into the crevice and wedge
between the rocks
they'll stay there protected for the
next 11 months
this rare footage shows a five-month-old
Port Jackson shark inside its egg
even as an embryo she must be vigilant
using Electro receptors she senses
Predators close by and freezes
even stopping her Gill movements to
avoid detection
but not all eggs are so lucky
if an egg rolls into the open it's fair
game
this crested horn shark looks a lot like
a Port Jackson
they're close cousins but there is no
familial love here
on his menu is Port Jackson shark egg
before this crested horn can break
through the filament of the egg casing
a male Port Jackson approaches
it seems that help has arrived
poor Jacks and sharks are larger than
crested horns and this one has the
advantage
the crested horn isn't going to give up
his meal that easily
the Port Jackson has to step up
he grabs the egg from the smaller shark
but this was not a rescue mission
the Port Jackson will keep this egg for
himself
just like a chicken egg the yellow yolk
is dense with nutrients to feed the
shark embryo
an exposed egg represents a meal for
anything that can break through the
tough egg case
nearly 90 percent of the eggs don't make
it to hatching
has survived those odds
just a couple of days old and seven
inches long she's not much bigger than
some muscle shells
she'll have to learn to feed herself
quickly
the jaws of an adult Port Jackson are
filled with crushing molars and razor
sharp teeth
but the baby's teeth and Jaws are not
fully developed yet
so she sucks in worms and other
soft-bodied animals to eat
but she's not the only one out to find a
meal
predators are on the prowl
and baby Port Jackson is on the menu
this Fiddler Ray is on the hunt
using electroreceptors in its snout
called ampulay of lorenzini the race
scans the sea floor for his next meal
looking for shellfish crabs and even
small fish like baby Port Jackson's
just like inside the egg she freezes in
an attempt to hide
but this baby shark has another trick up
her sleeve
the coloring of her skin acts as
camouflage
mimicking dappled light on the Sandy
Bottom
and by avoiding detection
she gets to Live Another Day
it will be at least 11 years before this
baby shark is sexually mature
and able to join in the annual Port
Jackson breeding season here in Jarvis
Bay
it's September nearly a year since the
poor beagle scientists were in the icy
waters of the Gulf of Maine
Dr James sulakowski and his team are on
a mission to catch a baby poor beagle
shark
some lines in the water hopefully catch
us a baby poor beagle all right let's
get those tags on let's get the tags on
for the first time ever the research
team is here to catch a baby poor beagle
and fit it with a newly developed
baby-sized satellite tag
so we know that the baby poor beagle
sharks are here in the Gulf of Maine but
we don't exactly know why they're using
this habitat so we've got a rod set at
the surface
we've got a rod set at about 50 feet and
one set at about 100 feet we do this
because we know based on our data that
baby poor beagles use the whole water
column so now no matter what depth that
baby poor beagle is swimming at we have
a good chance of catching it
little baby poor because they're
mysterious they like to nibble around
the bait and sometimes it's gone
so there you go it's gone little baby
poor people nibbled around that that
hook so we're gonna put some more bait
on there and give it another try
this Phantom shark appears to be living
up to its name
but their luck finally seems to change
all right ladies gentlemen look at this
okay all right here we go
here we go he's got a good hook
come on
come on all right look at this beautiful
shark okay okay calm down baby poor
beagles or as we like to call them pork
chops are some of the cutest sharks
because they really look like miniature
versions of the adults they're small but
they're really chunky all right I need
somebody on tail yeah all right all
right I got tails get on his head all
right this is a baby poor beagle thank
God we have been searching for this
little shark forever what a beautiful
shark
look at his color look at this great big
blue eyes this shark is probably about
two months old look at this little thing
it's so cute this is a cute little shark
this is what we're after come on little
buddy at less than three feet from tip
to tail she may be small but this baby
shark is pure muscle and packs a heck of
a punch the team keeps a firm grip on
her for safety
and so we're super excited right now
this is the first time that we're
putting this tag on this shark
and so this could mean
literally everything for the survival of
this particular shark but also for the
species if this is a nursery ground we
have to know this in order to protect
these areas Dr sulakowski is the first
scientist to deploy a baby-sized
satellite tag on a baby poor beagle
tags we've used in the past to track
movement were just too big for babies
and so we needed to figure out a way in
order to find where babies were going so
we had to develop new technology and
this new satellite tag is smaller it's
lighter and it actually grows with that
shark so it protects that fin it doesn't
hurt the shark and we can really get
some great movement on baby poor beagles
[Music]
[Applause]
baby poor beagles share this area with
commercial fishing boats and are
sometimes caught by accident
information on the baby's movements will
help the scientists work with the
fishing Community to avoid catching this
vulnerable species
right here we're not shark surfaces this
will transmit to a location from a
satellite that's that's passing above so
we'll know exactly where that shark is
at that time it's amazing it's real time
real world information
right now we're going to release this
shark back to the ocean one two three a
slime
okay right here we go we're gonna place
the shark in three oh yeah look at it go
this baby shark is safely back in the
water
it's only a matter of time before she
surfaces again and starts transmitting
data back to the scientists
oh my gosh yeah totally insane
it's just so incredible to see it to see
those big eyes to see that thick tail
that fusiform body those dark coloration
see it swimming so aggressively away
it's just you know something that we as
scientists it's like Christmas day it's
unbelievable for us wow now the fun
begins now we track this little shark we
see where it goes we see what habitat
it's using we see how it's interacting
with the commercial fishing industry and
we can see how we can get everybody
working together to help this little
shark survive
yeah
official efficient
tagging the baby poor beagle with the
newly developed satellite tag is a huge
first for science
and before the end of the day the team
get their first ping look at that it's
the day before we go we just released
it's already surfacing and transmitting
that's great news I mean that means that
shark's alive it's coming to the surface
and hopefully will give us a lot of data
from here on out
these are the first data points of many
as this poor beagle grows in the waters
around Cape Cod
there's baby sharks here
if this area is a nursery ground how are
they using it
and how does it connect back to Mom
these are all major questions for us and
if they are using this as a nursery
ground then this is a really special
place it'd be the first Nursery ground
ever for this species which is
incredible to think about
the poor beagle is a shark shrouded in
mystery but with more research being
done scientists hope to have a better
understanding of their place in the
ocean
starting right here in this potential
Nursery ground
in Australia baby sharks are being
impacted by a changing ocean
and scientists are on a mission to
understand how they can survive
in places like here off Heron Island on
the southern tip of the Great Barrier
Reef
a mix of tropical water and cooler water
from the south make this one of the most
productive places on the reef
yeah
and it's home to one of the world's
strangest shark species the epaulette
shark
they are also one of the world's
smallest sharks growing to only a few
feet in length
and the babies are even tinier
only around six inches long
like the Port Jackson shark epaulets lay
eggs the females hide them under Coral
heads to keep them safe from predators
after only a few months the baby
epaulette emerges ready for a life on
the reef
but it's not the size of epaulettes that
makes them special
from birth these sharks have an
astounding ability
they can walk the only family of shark
that's able to do this
while sharks have been in the ocean for
over 400 million years
epaulettes evolve this behavior only 9
million years ago
making them the most recently evolved
sharks in the world
his round muscular fins act like feet to
help him into the Titan nooks and
crannies of the reef
where he'll find food
hide from predators
and deploy an ingenious strategy
when The Tide is High large five foot
long white tip reef sharks dominate The
Reef
but when the tide is low the white tip
is too big to maneuver here
it's a situation that epaulettes use to
their advantage
[Music]
the fierce tides on Heron Island pull
water off the reef at an alarming rate
leaving a shallow landscape of Trapped
water
most fish move to deeper water off the
reef as the tide goes out
or risk being stranded
the epaulette exploits this extreme
tidal change to hunt when the
competition is locked out
but as the time continues to recede the
epaulette faces a challenge
these isolated tide pools are low in
oxygen
making it difficult for most fish to
breathe
but the epaulette has another unique
ability
he can survive out of water
he slows his breathing and heart rate
and shuts off parts of his brain
now he can live for up to an hour
without any Oxygen before reconnecting
with the sea
epaulettes are the only shark that can
do this
it's an adaptation that has helped them
thrive in places like this where the
reef experiences dramatic changes in
short periods of time
while epaulette sharks have mastered the
ability to cope with extreme changes in
oxygen levels
how they react to extremes in
temperature is unknown
I see a tail
holy cow
oh nice so camouflaged all right let's
get this one yep
got him and we go one little one nice
work PhD student Carolyn wheeler and Dr
Jody rummer from James Cook University
are here to study the temperature
tolerance of epaulette sharks and what
it could mean for their future in a
warming climate
when the low tides coincide with the
afternoon times like that it gets really
warm on the reflat there's not a lot of
water and it heats up really quickly
so the sharks have to be really tough to
be able to handle these kind of short
temperature windows in the afternoon on
the reflat here
let's catch a number of sharks of
different ages which they can tell by
their size and weight
second then they measure the water
temperature where they find the sharks
water that's too warm will stress the
sharks there are two life history stages
that are particularly vulnerable the
first is early life history so when the
sharks are developing in their egg case
so when they're embryos and soon after a
hatching
and the second vulnerable life stage is
reproducing adults they're putting a lot
of energy into creating the precursors
of eggs and so this also is a very
vulnerable stage
unlike baby Port Jackson sharks which
take 11 months to incubate in their
Corkscrew X
baby epaulettes spend only four months
growing inside their eggs before they
hatch
just four months from a tiny wriggling
worm-like creature
this mini shark it's one of the shortest
incubation periods of any shark species
but as water temperatures rise babies
that are heat stressed consume their
yolk sacks more quickly
and they hatch almost a month earlier
than average
[Music]
when the baby sharks are born earlier
they're weaker than normal and unable to
perform normal functions as well such as
learning to walk and hunting for food
and the temperature is quite High yeah
what is the temperature it's 26.6
degrees Celsius which is about 78
degrees Fahrenheit
reflats like this one can vary
drastically with each changing tide
a low tide in the middle of the day can
be up to 50 degrees Fahrenheit hotter
than a high tide in the early morning or
at night
it takes a lot of energy to grow from a
tiny embryo into a baby shark
[Music]
so any additional stress can be a big
problem
we're really trying to understand how
challenging environmental conditions are
costing epileptic sharks more energy to
live
so we are using this species epaulette
shark as an indicator species because
they're so tough if we find thresholds
or trigger points that are challenging
for them that is a very good early
warning system for us for the health of
the reef not just the Great Barrier Reef
but reefs in general around the world
in a changing climate sharks are still
key to the health of the ocean
beginning with baby sharks
[Music]